[Music]
[Music]
in a moving speech to the european
parliament 100 year old holocaust
survivor margot friedlander recalled
seeing auschwitz inmates arriving at the
trajan stat concentration camp where she
was imprisoned
the horrors that took place in auschwitz
are unspeakable
but we must speak this is a day
of remembrance today
the 27th of january marks our collective
responsibility
to remember the unspeakable atrocities
committed towards all the victims of the
holocaust
parliament members and representatives
of eu institutions gathered to
commemorate the anniversary of the
auschwitz liberation and pledge to never
let the horrors of world war ii happen
again
we speak up against
holocaust deniers
against conspiracy myths
against disinformation
and against violence of every kind
that target and single out members of
our communities
the european parliament promised to
continue combating exclusion
marginalization and hatred towards
minorities
[Music]
the commemoration ended with a minute of
silence in honor of all victims of the
holocaust
you